the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today I'm going to talk about signatures
and all sorts of different signature
kind of things in the in the problem set
you're you're working with signatures
but you're working with hash based
signatures which are not actually used
in Bitcoin at all but we'll talk about
those okay so if you've gotten through
the homework
there's Lamport signatures right these
are hash based signatures and they use
hash functions so it's fairly
straightforward like you know you can
understand them there's nothing super
crazy going on the code is fairly
compact so that's cool what are some
disadvantages of these Lamport
signatures does anyone like yeah yeah
okay so okay plus ashes that's cool
one-time use other possible
disadvantages of them relative to other
systems you're aware another is they're
kind of huge kind of big right not you
know you can deal with it
but if you are looking in the like Forge
or that that file with the signatures
but it's like what eight eight K first
signature eight kilobytes kind of big
keys are 16 kilobytes kind of annoying
private keys are also 16 kilobytes so
yes sig 8k 16 K proved palm key so
that's some disadvantages so since I
don't have slides you make this sort of
more fun and interactive what are some
solutions for these problems so we can
actually mitigate
solve both of these things to a pretty
pretty good extent so how about the
first one one time use what would be a
fairly obvious way to mitigate the
one-time use problem and like don't
think the answer is is too stupid like
it may be a fairly stupid answer into I
work yeah
there's probably some clever way but
that might be too clever like something
really simple for okay I can only use a
key once how can I use a key
quote-unquote more than once
yeah so you can say well I've got this
16 kilobyte public key well I'm gonna
make a 32 kilobyte public key and it's
just two public keys stuck together and
now when I mean you know and now when I
make a signature I just put an extra bit
in the front and I say well this
signature is using key 0 or this
signature is using key 1 and it's got
the whole signature after and then you
look through this 32 kilobyte public
keen you say okay well it starts with a
0 so that means it's using the first key
you know the first sub key in this 32
byte public key block and in this case
that's using 1 so that means it's using
the second you know the latter sub key
so that would work that would let you
use the signature the your public key
twice at the cost of doubling your
public key size which is not really
great right it that's not a great if
it's not very efficient but it does sort
of work okay any any clever ways to do
it more efficiently or wait so okay also
so I'll give you sort of a hint in this
case let's say this is you know pub sub
0 and pub sub 1 right and then like
you're 32 byte pump key is the stem
concatenated together right of 0 1 what
would happen to the private keys in this
case right
how would private keys work here same
expansion of size I guess and you can
anyone think of a way to to mitigate the
expansion of size of private keys in
this case so the private keys are sort
of you know the Prima
here right they lead into these public
key blocks so you could just say okay
well I have twice the size private key
leading into twice the size public key
could you do that more efficiently yeah
yes so how would you tell let's say you
have this 16 K block and you want this
to turn into two public keys so that's
that's the that's the basic good way to
do it and it sort of like turns in like
that
how exactly like what's a way you did
that yeah so so this is a hash function
right and so before we just said okay
hash of you know this is like block 0
this is block 1 this is block 2 so the
idea of you know pub let's say this is
invisible this might be kind of too
small right yes okay let me let me put
this bigger okay so in these in these
diagrams
you've got your your private key right
now and it's in these big blocks and
there's 256 of them but let's keep it
small and the idea is these are 32 byte
blocks with random numbers in it and
then you hash it to get your public key
and this is you know so we say okay pub
2 and this is you know public this is
private let's say secret pub 2 is just
the hash of secret - right well yeah
what we could do is we could put them to
have two different hash functions and
then a a real simple way to make a whole
bunch of different hash functions is we
sort of define okay well hash 0 is
defined as the hash function of you know
whatever your input X is concatenated
with the number 0 and then the hash 1 we
define as just X comma 1 and so on and
this is this is actually secure you
could do this
any questions or possible objections yes
so so this is like you know there's no
real entropy or secrets in this zero and
one so but it's it's purely riding on X
right so but the idea is well if I do
this and like you know I say okay well
pub to you is secret to concatenated
with zero yeah if you no secret to you
can go back because zero is obvious but
the idea is if you don't know secret to
the fact that you know the last you know
bite of this what the hash input doesn't
really help you because there's all this
you know all this data that you don't
know and so you're not going to be able
to find a pre-image you're like okay I
know the preimage to public to ends with
a zero byte what are the other 32 bytes
that come before that like you can't you
still can't go back to make a pre-image
the second to last byte is gonna be in
so the attack is I've got pump two which
is a 32 byte hash output I want to find
what this thing is now I do know what
the last byte is right it's gonna be
let's say 33 bytes and the last fight is
a 0 and this is gonna be some you know
random numbers all the way back so I
have sort of you know I have some
insight into what the preimage is I know
the last byte is a zero but that doesn't
help because I don't know all the the
bytes before that so I can't really do
any you know I can't I can't sign
because I don't I need to be able to
reveal all these things and the way the
hash function if it's a good hash
function the fact that you know some
part of the preimage shouldn't give you
insight into the other parts of the
preimage because it's like looks really
random and you know adding adding stuff
to the end here
like reveal and thing there are hash
functions where this can be dangerous
and you can consider those like broken
hash functions where if I if I
concatenate a lot of known data at the
end it might give me you know properties
of the public key that I can find shot
to v6 as far as we know doesn't you know
it works fine most of the hash functions
work fine this way so yeah you can do
this and then you can say okay well I'm
gonna use hash function 1 or hash
function 0 to make pub keys 0 right this
is funky 0 and if I use hash function 1
I make punky one now I have a 16
kilobyte this so now what I can do is I
can say okay well I have a 16 kilobyte
secret key private key but I have a 32
kilobyte public key that's that I can
use twice that is two sub keys so I
don't have to store as much of my
private key data so that's cool that
makes it quite a bit more efficient does
anyone have an idea of how to get it
even more efficient for private key
storage you can actually get it very
efficient using this kind of idea it is
what would you you so some hints this is
pretty useful right the idea is well
even if you know what the sort of suffix
of all these things are if you don't
know X you're not gonna be able to find
the preimage right so maybe add some
more stuff here any idea of so another
big yeah right right so instead of just
saying 0 & 1 we can say like we can say
here well why not just have one chunk
and you say hash 0 you know hash hash
like let's list one chunk and it's got
you know random number X well this is
hash x comma 0 this is hash x comma 1
this is ash x comma 2 okay so yeah so
what you can do is you can this was
before right where I said okay yeah but
this is basically how to do a 32 byte
private key where your private key is
actually quite small and you just derive
all of the public keys by adding numbers
at the end concatenating them into your
hash and now you're like okay cool I
have a 32 byte private key and I can
make enormous public keys from them and
it's still secure right because I can
add whatever number I want here and I
can do this a million times and no one
will be able to find the preimage even
though I'm giving you all these related
hashes right it's X comma zero X comma 1
X comma a million I can give you
millions of them and it each time I do
it it doesn't give you any insight into
how to find what X is if it's a good
hash function so that's really powerful
and now I can say okay the private key
problem is solved I have like o of one
growth in my private key I can make as
many public keys as I want never gets
any bigger cool still have this problem
with the public key so let's say I want
to sign for x okay while I make a 64
64 kilobyte pump key now I can sign four
times great but my my public key size
expands with the number of signatures I
ever wanted to any any ideas on how you
could mitigate that or how you could
still make a usable system despite this
fact there's a there's a couple sort of
different techniques any ideas
okay so one would be every time I sign I
also sign my next pub key you can do
that it's got some some downsides right
so the idea is I just commit you know I
first published one 16 kilobyte pub key
and then I say okay when I sign I'm
going to sign my message and
concatenated that message will be my
next pub key and so I'm signing
something and also indicating what my
next public key will be that I signed
with then I can still maintain a small
private key and then keep signing the
problem is in order for someone to
verify they're gonna need to look at all
of my previous signatures right so if I
if I'm saying hey here's my 500th public
key that I'm signing with here's the
message you're gonna have to go back and
look at my entire history of signing
it's not great okay so other ideas of
how to how to deal with large pump keys
what's the way you could do this
so hints is there any kind of data
function we've seen here where it takes
an arbitrary sized amount of data and
outputs a fixed size in fact it's the
only thing we've been talking about so
far so what would you do to make your
public he's smaller - yeah right okay so
you say well yeah 32 byte pump key well
you just commit to the pump key with the
hash of the whole thing right and I say
well I've got I've got my I've got my 16
kilobyte pump key
I just hash it right and now I have a 32
byte public key and I've committed that
that works right I've committed to my
public key however when I sign I need to
provide the whole public key in order
for you to verify you know I need to
provide this whole 16 original pub key
you know original version pub key after
when I sign so now my signature goes
from 8k to what 24 K so I haven't really
made it more efficient right in that
like the total thing with like public
keys and signatures stays the same size
actually slightly larger but this is
kind of a gain because the public key I
mean it might be like I'm showing it to
you beforehand and it we're space
constrained there and then when I'm
doing the signature have more space or
time or something like that so this is
actually useful and actually this
technique is used in you know Bitcoin
and all different crypto currencies
where you know you can call this a punky
punky hash or they say pkh and the main
benefit is size right you could say well
if I've got a really big punky I can
commit to it by sending to the hash of
the pub key and then when I later want
to sign I reveal the actual pub key you
do it that way okay so then this is
pretty cool right we've now got we've
taken our system which had fairly large
16 kilobyte private keys turn them into
32 byte private keys great and also this
is o of 1 never expands awesome we've
taken a system with large potentially
you know huge 32 kilobyte 64 kilobyte
public keys we've got it down to 32
bytes awesome ok
we've now made this thing much more
efficient much more useful the problem
the signatures are still big they
actually got a little bit bigger because
they include the full public key
in the signature and let's say we had a
you know one of the things where we make
a bunch of public keys and commit to
them at the outset so he said okay I've
got a 64 kilobyte pub key I can commit
to the whole thing by hashing it however
then when I reveal and want to give you
a signature my signature is now whatever
it'll be like 72 right signature would
be 72 kilobytes kind of huge so I can
add a bunch of keys but I'm just sort of
like pushing the problem somewhere else
into the signature right there's a
better way to commit too many public
keys it's maybe not super obvious unless
you've seen it before but if you have do
you know what the better way to commit
to many public keys is or you could come
up with a day on the spot and to be like
wow you should have gotten this stuff
named after you any idea okay so what
you can do it like it's a little
non-obvious you can make a tree right so
the idea is instead of just saying oh
I'm going to take all four of my big pub
keys stick them all in a row take the
hash of that whole thing and publish
that as my public key hash I'm gonna
have a little bit more complex design
and that design is a binary tree okay so
the idea is here are my four public keys
that take up you know 64 KH I can make
these intermediate hashes so I make a
binary tree where I say okay this is the
hash of the first two keys stuck
together this is the hash of the second
two keys stuck together the top is the
hash of these two intermediate hashes
stuck together and then this top is sort
of my root which is equivalent to my pub
key hash and so I can publish this and
it is committed it commits me to all
four of my public keys so what it might
not be obvious are there do you see any
advantages that this could have
over just concatenating all four of the
keys and hashing it the private key is
down here right the private key is not
shown but it turn you know I have a
private key turns into this bump keys
and we can use the technique here where
we just have really one 32 byte private
key and create all the different chunks
of all the public keys right by
concatenating different indices yeah so
if I want to exactly I can prove that
hey this is public key zero which is in
here this root hash and I don't have to
reveal all four in order to do it so
yeah then II did someone else have
probably the same idea yeah okay okay so
how are we going to do that maybe I mean
you obviously know anyone else have ya
right yeah and then you can prove up to
the top so I have little colors the idea
is the the receive you know the verifier
who's verifying a signature and already
he already knows the route right because
you've sort of pre published that as
your public key
it's your public key route your public
key hash and then you're provided that
verifier is provided with public key
zero saying hey here's a signature
here's the message
here's public key zero so you've got
both of these things now the prover
needs to prove that public key zero is
contained within the route and to do
that the only two things you need to add
the prover needs to add is pub one okay
so the prove ourselves once the verifier
to compute this and then the prover says
hey here's hash two three which allows
the verifier to compute the route and
then check that it's equal so yeah you
only need two extra hashes instead of
all four so save some space it doesn't
save that much space when you only have
four it saves a lot of space when you
have a thousand right so you can add you
know event n elements and the route the
route stays the same size the route say
is 32 bytes regardless of how many Leafs
leaf nodes you have and you can prove an
element with login no parentheses are
wrong Oh
login intermediate hashes so if you have
a thousand keys your route stays 32
bytes and your proofs are going to be
not too too big right 320 bytes of
overhead which is somewhat like a bunch
smaller than a signature right so this
is really cool and you can use this much
more practically than the sort of raw
Lamport signatures that were in the
first problem set because those you know
if you're just doing one key in one
signature it's about the same size but
this actually lets you use it multiple
times lets you store a much smaller
private key commit to much smaller
public keys it's a more usable system
the signatures though still are
of huge right you'd have your signatures
are gonna be a little over eight
kilobytes which is okay right computers
can be able to eight kilobytes
that's called a Merkel tree and made by
Ralph Merkle in like seventy six or
something and it was originally made for
exactly that purpose anyway so these are
called Merkel trees
Ralph Merkle he doesn't really work on
Krypton I work something like biotech
stuff and I think cool and he gets like
everything named after I'm so you will
see the word Merkel like everywhere and
it's like you know he invented something
cool awesome this is one of the kind of
things though where it seems like yeah I
might have been able to think of that
right it's sort of a binary tree and
hash functions like it's nothing that
crazy but so there's all sorts of you
know Merkel trees you can make it
different you know it's used in Bitcoin
it's used in a bunch of different crypto
currencies it's a very cool it's a very
you know powerful way to take a whole
bunch of different things and commit to
them in one small thing okay so this is
very cool but we can do better and so
the next things are things that I
definitely would never have thought of
because it's much more complex than just
like hey let's use a binary tree with
hashes and I will mention RSA and then
go into ECDSA and I left a curve blare
in evidence signatures which do
different things and are not based on
just ash functions so I'll talk about
RSA for a few minutes and then we'll
have a look a little break like
intermission and then we'll go into the
elliptic curve stuff
okay so RSA was invented by locals the
are is is Ron no I think the R stands
for Rivest but Ron Rivest is at csail
and he's you know working on still
working on cool crypto stuff it's not
used in Bitcoin or any currency actually
that well any currently operating
cryptocurrency
because they the signatures and keys are
a bit larger than the later systems will
see smaller than the hash based things
but still a bit larger was used in cha
me and blinded cash because you can do
what blinded signatures where you say
okay I'm gonna have you
sign something for me and then after you
give me the signature I can sort of pull
apart the signature and you won't
because you I'll have you sign something
that you don't know what you're signing
right I'm gonna like mask this message
and blind it so that you sign the
message and then I can get your
signature on the real message without
you knowing what you signed so basically
the idea is well I actually have you
know message prime equals message plus
randomness and I say hey can you sign em
Prime and you say okay I produce a
signature on M Prime with my you know
private key and we'll call that s Prime
and then what I can do is I can sort of
s equals s prime minus the randomness or
really some function of that randomness
and now I have a signature and this is a
valid signature on em so that's kind of
cool it's like hey can you sign this
message for me and I'm not gonna tell
you what you're signing and then it
seems sort of useless like why would I
sign something I have no idea what I'm
saying but it can be used in that that
Chou Mian blinded cache because I then
have a proof that well this bank didn't
know what they were signing but they
they signed this and this is their
signature and they gave it to me and I
can use that as like a thing to
represent money that there's all sorts
of cool things you can do with this um
the basic setup of RSA is make two prime
numbers P and Q and then compute n which
is the product P times Q so this seems
fairly straightforward right it's not
too hard everyone knows the prime
numbers are now you have this composite
number P times Q what how do I like make
a leading question for the next slide
does this have any relation to things
we've looked at like does this look this
doesn't look at all like a hash function
right but are there any properties
similar to a hash function here yeah
yeah it's a one-way function in that if
I know if he and Q I can compute n right
but given n I can't necessarily find P
and Q right if they're small sure I just
sort of
check and there's all sorts of
algorithms to find factors but if P and
Q are pretty big like hundreds of bits
long thousands of bits long finding it
may be impractical
whereas if P and Q are really long
finding the product of both of them will
be very practical even if even if huge
multiplying two integers is like really
easy so this is a one-way function but
not a hash function and so a lot of
these signature systems use one-way
functions but trickier one-way functions
that aren't hash functions and still
have things that you like cool things
that you can do so I'm not gonna go into
RSA in super detail I'm going to sort of
like run through it really quick and
you'll be like huh how does that work
but if you think it's interesting you
can look it up and then maybe go to C
cell and ask Ron how it works although
maybe try to look it up first he's
probably explained it a lot of times and
but it has different properties so you
could say I'm gonna use this P times Q
equals n as like a hash function and
make a Lamport signature out of it where
my private key is a whole bunch of P and
Q pairs and my public key is a whole
bunch of ends and I reveal them and
stuff you could do that that would work
but you can do much more powerful things
because of the mathematical properties
of these things so yeah I'm just gonna
go through it really fast cos but if you
think it's you know if you if you know
anything that's kind of cool the idea is
you can do a bunch of multiplication and
exponentiation modulo n and so because n
is like almost prime there's some
interesting properties where if you know
the factors of n you have these
shortcuts you can do and if someone who
doesn't know the factors of n can't do
these shortcuts so you publish E which
is a constant this is sort of a
parameter system usually today so RSA is
used today all over the place if you're
on if your computer is open and you've
been using the web in the last five
seconds your computer has performed RSA
calculations every time you connect to a
website you're doing RSA so generally at
six five five three seven they just make
this up you can do also use three
some small number and then D is a number
that you can compute if you know what P
and Q are so this is sort of the private
key right P and Q itself can be seen as
the private key but you can actually
compute this demon number and then
discard P and Q and then yeah so this is
how you compute D or whatever but the
idea is n is their public key and D is
your private key E is always the same
and P and Q you can discard afterwards
and then what you can do and this is
like not going to get into it but you
can say okay my signature s is message
right I can take the hash and make a
message message to the D power modulo N
and if I verify if I take that signature
to the e power modulo n it should equal
M again which is like crazy and kind of
awesome because the idea is to sign okay
I just raised to the D power mod n it's
gonna be some some number on you know
the same size as n right and then I give
that to someone they take that signature
to the six hundred you know six five
five three seven power modulo and again
and see if n comes back out em the
message comes back out and if it does
they know I signed and I have the
private key the private key that
corresponds to n now this the cool thing
is I can use this any number of times I
can use it the same thing a bazillion
times with different M's and that
doesn't give any help on to how to
factor n or how to compute D so this was
you know late 70s also RSA and sort of
one of the first like hey we you know we
can do better than hash functions it
sort of was developed at around the same
time as hash based signatures all of
these things were sort of coming out of
the same time you can do lots of cool
stuff because there's like these
properties where we can you know make em
you know M prime plus m and like take
the exponentiation of all that and still
it works ok so that's really cool you
can do lots of cool stuff but this is
also not used in Bitcoin one of the
things that
sighs Sookie sizes are smaller than then
with Lamport signatures and they're
often about two kilobits or 256 bytes
which is fine and that's about the same
size as signatures so if you use your
like web browser secure well how secure
certificate valid no this browser might
not show me okay anyway well in Firefox
that tells you more okay well anyway
anyway anyway but yeah you there's RSA
keys in basically every certificate for
web browsers and websites and they're
generally 2048 bits long that scene is
like pretty secure that's like you know
even a thousand four thousand twenty
four bits has not been hacked but people
think it probably could be by a very
motivated actor so this is decent size
one thing about RSA is that it's a
little tricky to implement right there's
a whole bunch of weird math there it's
not like the Lamport signatures where
it's like okay I have a hash function
use it right it's it's kind of hard to
shoot yourself in the foot with the
Lamport signature scheme you can write
but it's sort of obvious if you do so
like if you're doing the homework and it
just like doesn't work at all and you're
like oh I was hashing twice or oh I was
like reversing the order or you know
things that were like it it it just
didn't work but there's no like subtle
ways where like oh I was off by one and
now it reveals all my private keys
that's hard to do whereas an RSA it's
actually quite easy if if your P and Q
values for example what's it what's a
really crazy gotcha if P or Q minus one
so if like P minus 1 or Q minus 1 is
smooth essentially a number that's
highly composite has many small factors
you can find someone's private key you
can factor it so it's not just that P
and Q have to be prime P minus 1 and Q
minus 1 have to be not two unprimed not
like it can't be like a power of two or
something otherwise you can lose your
project so there's all sorts of like you
know crazy things that happen with RSA
Bitcoin and other coins use elliptic
curve signatures which I'll talk about
next
that have our sort of displacing RSA in
many cases so it hasn't really taken off
for for like web certificates but a lot
of other types of encryption signing
things like that like crypto currencies
are also one of the big uses of elliptic
curve signatures because they're
somewhat more powerful and somewhat
smaller and really cool and we will talk
about those in three minutes so
intermission three minutes stretch ask
random questions talk to the neighbors
okay so they're using these elliptic
curves which are curves of the form y
squared plus X cubed plus X some
coefficient x squared plus some constant
and in the case of Bitcoin it's very
simple it's y squared equals x cubed
plus seven and that's the curve bitcoin
uses and this is what it looks like if
you plot it and that seems really simple
like we can totally understand that but
it gets a little weird with elliptic
curves you have these points on the
curves right and another property is if
you draw a straight line that intersects
this curve you could also draw a line
which doesn't intersect at all fine but
if you draw a line that intersects the
curve it will intersect in three places
so if I draw a line here it intersects
these three dots if I draw a line here
and intersects here here and then it'll
intersect somewhere down here it'll
intersect in three places unless I take
a tangent if I draw and I like try to be
like oh I'm gonna only intersect in two
well I can take a tangent here and it'll
intersect in one more place what we can
do those we can say well if you
intersect at a tangent that's kind of
like intersecting twice or you know we
can we can deal with that
if you draw a vertical oh yeah vertical
line then there's like a point at
infinity which shouldn't happen
yeah yeah it there's a point up there
sort of it in the practice of signing
and stuff you probably shouldn't hit it
like if you yeah but so what we do is we
say okay well three points in a line
equals zero and so if we take this point
plus this point plus this point that's
zero another way to say that is P plus Q
minus R equals 0 or P plus Q equals
negative R and another property is the
negation of a point is just that same
point with the you know y-coordinate
flipped so this is you know if this is
negative R we just go down to the bottom
side of this and this is positive R
similarly you know minus P would be here
minus Q would be here and if you had a
point
you know Z here negative Z would be up
here this is how it's constructed
however we don't actually use these nice
curves we sort of chop them up and
modulo something yeah
no in this case are as I hit right P in
this case P wait hold on
people speak equals R right sorry okay
normally yeah
the this picture is correct
but so basically P plus Q equals R
because R is down here sorry yeah that's
why okay this is our this is negative R
so so yeah people ask you equals
negative if equals are not negative R
sorry when you want to multiply a point
you can because you can take a tangent
right so you can add these points right
you can say okay I want the sum of P and
Q which will be down here are I want to
pee for example well with two P I can
take a tangent and then find where it
intersects and then go down below okay
so for example if this is you know G I
say okay well G starts here take the
tangent find where it intersects and
then drop down and this is to G so I can
you know it's a simple way to say well
I'm not I'm not really multiplying I'm
just adding it to itself which is sort
of what multiplication is and I can do
this again and again so I say oh I want
for G I take the tangent at to G find
the intersection here drop down okay
here's for G take the tangent here it'll
go you know I can keep doing that and
get to g4 g AG and if I want
intermediate things like well I want
three G well I'm draw a line between G
and two G find the intersection and find
the sum so what we yeah yes
yeah yeah so so it looks I the pictures
look nice in this case right it's like a
this is this curve and it looks so
simple and we can like graphically do it
on graph paper but when you're actually
doing it on the computer it looks more
like this
everything is modulo some giant prime
number
the you could still draw lines it's just
that the curve is now all these
crazy-looking dots and you still have
that symmetry from the y-axis but the
way the computer does it is all modulo
number so you can't it doesn't actually
map to a nice like curve however all the
properties so the fun thing about when
you're doing modulo is all the
properties stay the same right like you
can still do with with regular numbers
you can still do addition multiplication
and division all modulo some number and
it still all works right so same with
this you still have the same you know
draw a line between P and Q and you get
to here and then you flip over the
y-axis and now this is R similarly you
can like take a tangent
although tangent is harder to visually
see because there's no like obvious
curve here but the equations work the
same okay so you don't need to like know
exactly why these things work or curves
but we're gonna go through what you can
do with these and what properties you
have okay so we've now have we've
defined these points on a curve and like
how this curve works and then we also
have regular old numbers right so a and
well what we'll do from now on is say
like a and B are lowercase numbers these
are scalars scalars just means regular
old numbers the upper case a and B will
refer to points on the curve okay so
from now on lower case is regular number
upper case is point on this curve or
point on this mashed-up thing that we
still call a current okay so I'll go
through what operations we can do and
then we can see what use those that
so first scalars you can add subtract
multiply divide you can do
ever you want right these are just
regular numbers like five or 17 or 20 -
everything is okay
right easy everything here is integers
we're doing modulo some big prime number
so there's no decimal points you know
you never have to use I think in this
class we'll probably never have to use
floating-point which is great because
floating-point always scares me it's
like it's also like you int these are
like unsigned integers you can do it
with sine but since you're modulo some
big number it's like unsigned numbers
that loop around so it's really nice for
computers computers deal very well with
these things computers are good at
floating-point as well but the thing is
in cryptography a lot of times
floating-point ends up with error right
where you're like pretty close but like
you're you've got some you know fixed
amount of decimal places you can store
your floating-point goes out to some
precision and then air can sort of
accumulate and in a lot of cryptography
you want zero error right like in a hash
function it's pretty exact so in a lot
of times the cryptography you you use
integers instead of floating-point or
rational numbers okay so with scalars
these are just regular integers natural
numbers even you can do these all the
operations you're familiar with that's
fairly straightforward with points so
you can add and subtract the points
right we showed how you sort of do that
visually and then the equations for it
the computer can do that pretty quick
however these this is not defined
multiplication and division with two
points is undefined it's just not it's
not clear how you do it like it's it's
not something in this system right it's
a group you've got one operation you
don't have this other one so you can add
them subtract points if you can't
multiply them
any questions about this this is a
pretty important yeah make sense yes
when you adding points what is defined
as addition are you adding them either
you use both the x and y coordinates to
add right so right so when you're doing
it in the computer saying okay
well what are the x and y coordinates of
P what are the x and y coordinates of Q
draw you know find the slope find the
slope here and the like where it
intersects the axis and then see where
it'll intersect the curve at another
point you know but the equation would be
like you don't the sense the computer
doesn't actually look at the curve you
just say okay find the PX and y
coordinate find the Q X&Y coordinate
like find the slope and then find where
it intersects and then like you know
compute for that Ferrar okay so yeah you
can add and subtract
you cannot multiply and divide these
points sounds good any other questions
you just go down right so if I want P
minus Q I just say P plus negative Q and
negative Q is just right here right down
on the y axis so I say okay I want
people ask you go here but it's gonna be
up there somewhere so yeah you just add
the negative of the number I guess
that's another thing I you know B minus
B like negative B is also an operation I
can do I can negate something which lets
me do subtraction okay
natural numbers modulo and just some
easy birthday curve so this is a and the
only things to find is addition and
subtraction or not right you can do the
same group operations without using
elliptic curves and so you can just do
exponentiation modulo a big prime number
I'm gonna use curves because it's what
is used in all the actual systems and
it's but but you you can sort of forget
about the curve after this right if you
say well look we just have these
uppercase numbers and these you know
these uppercase variables and these
lowercase variables and the fact that
it's on a curve we can sort of abstract
away and just know that we have these
different types essentially and when you
do when you're in the computer you're
just like yeah that's the point
that's a scalar here are the operations
I can do and I just run the functions
okay so the next part when you mix
scalars and points so mixed operations
you cannot add a point and an integer or
subtract a point in an integer like
that's not defined right you say okay
here's this point P minus seven like
well does that mean move the x axis does
that move do y like it's not defined
however you can do this right you can
multiply and divide so you can say well
a times two what you know you take the
tangent right it's just a plus a or a
times seven is we just break it out as a
plus a plus a plus a 17 times we can
also divide which is a little weird
because we have to find the the sort of
like inverse of B and then multiply by
that like the multiplicative inverse of
B modulo the the order but anyway you
can do these this is a little trickier
because you have to compute what sort of
like B to the negative one is and
multiply by that you can do it so you
can do these things where you have
points times scalars but you cannot have
yep yep to it so that was here you know
if this is G this is to G find the
tangent find the intersection and then
the gate okay so you can do you can do
that that's cool you cannot do that
okay so roster of operations we can do
this is it and this is sort of if you
think of that you can do all these cool
things it's sort of amazing all the
crazy things you can do with just these
operations right with regular numbers
you can do whatever you want that's
obvious and with these points you can
add them subtract them and when you mix
you can multiply and divide and that's
it okay any questions so far you don't
you don't have to worry too much about
the curves and all the math and stuff
but you just sort of say okay here's my
sort of toolbox here's what I can do
okay any questions good so now what we
can do is we can define a one way
function sort of like a hash function
sort of like multiplying P times Q to
get n what we will need in addition to
this is everyone picks some point on the
curve and we call it G and it's random
and we want it to be somewhat verifiably
random we just all have to agree on a
point and we'll call this the generator
point another property is that if you
keep since it's all modulo this number
if B is too big you'll sort of wrap
around right because it's all modulo
let's like n so it's called the
generator point because and every point
on the curve can be one if you keep you
know say 2g 3G 4G 5g eventually you'll
get back to G right it's all finite okay
so does anyone have an idea okay how
would we make some cool one-way function
given these operations and the fact that
we have an agreed upon point it's not
super obvious but it's actually fairly
straightforward once you see it
any ideas yeah scaler yep yep okay so
your private key let's say you private
private key lowercase a it's just some
256 bit random number scaler exactly the
same as you know it's 32 bytes like in a
LAN port signature and your public key
is just eight times G and your public
key is now a point on a curve we're
gonna call it uppercase a and you have a
32 by x-coordinate right because the the
x dimension is 256 bits 32 byte
y-coordinate so it's 64 bytes pretty
small anyone have a another quick
optimization on how you could reduce
this so like there's a lot of
optimization going on in like all these
different cryptocurrency systems because
they don't scale too well but any idea
of how to get that down you could so you
can hash it keep making them 32 bytes
there's a cooler there's a more sort of
useful way because but if you hash it
you still have to reveal it later right
so like it helps making a funky hash and
that's that's what Bitcoin did initially
is you'd have the 64 byte public keys
and then you'd sent to the hash and then
there's a nicer way any ideas okay so
the thing is its symmetric right so the
curve is symmetric about the y axis
or sorry x axis any ideas and then let
them figure out exactly where it is
right so you can encode the x coordinate
only and one bit for Y and then you're
down to 33 bytes it's a little annoying
because the 33 bytes well one of those
bytes is gonna be like empty they're
just gonna have one bit in it for like
up or down but whatever um so you can do
that and that's also really cool
okay any questions so far probably but I
don't think would be smaller I think
you'd have to probably have the same
size if you use some other coordinate
system
I haven't eivin yeah you could sort of
encode a slope and you say it intersects
and it's at the slope and which side of
the axis you probably could I think it
would end up the same size but yeah then
but it might be faster for some things
there's all sorts of different encoding
yeah so you might not be on the curve
but there's a similar problem here where
it might not be on the curve you can
encode a point that's also off the curve
and so when you actually get a public
key like over the wire in these systems
the first thing you usually do is make
sure like this is a valid public key and
it's actually on the curve because
there's a lot of points that aren't and
sometimes you can screw around with the
code that way yeah okay so scalar
multiplication a times G is basically
break it out as G Plus G Plus G Plus G
Plus G a times and G Plus G is find the
tangent of G and then find the
intersection right so this is G this is
to G right tangent intersect and then go
to the negation and so you just do that
a bazillion times however since you can
find two G and then you can double to G
to get for G and double for G to get a
chi you can come up with like powers of
two of G and then add those powers of
two to do a much more efficient addition
so that you can practically make you
know his little a is gonna be some huge
you know 50 digit you know decimal 50
digit number or whatever so you're gonna
have to do this like sort of two four
six eight binary expansion and then add
them all up okay so yeah
if you're chucking everything into into
some green says to get to get these your
district I think opinions curve yes it
feels like you do a 32-bit you use
basically originally you should be able
to get all the way down to 32 bits yeah
or you can do some a little what you can
do is you can just say look I'm only
going to allow public keys that are on
the top you know on the positive have
positive Y component and everything else
is disallowed
you could you could have that as like a
rule of your system and then you can get
rid of the Y bit but the thing is some
of the things do you know the y
coordinate does affect some of the
things like signatures things that
you'll later use so you can just say
okay look implicitly Y bit is positive
and you you lose them like one bit of
security because there is a difference
between the positive and negative thing
if you're doing signing oh but yeah it's
it's so some systems do do that and
makes things easier there's some signing
systems that do that okay I'm gonna go
to the next part
there's ECDSA is used in Bitcoin I'm
actually not going to explain it it's a
worse signature system so the reason why
this was used was the better system was
patented and so there's a clearer sort
of more like obvious cleaner more
powerful
signature system that was patented by
this german guy
Klaus noir and so no one used it or
maybe a few people used it but in
general with like open-source things and
and like web standards patents are sort
of really hard to work with and so all
the cryptographers said well we'll make
this other system that's different
enough that it doesn't infringe on the
patent and it's kind of ugly it does
work as a signature scheme
but actually I'm going to explain the
Schnoor signatures which make a lot more
sense are easier to understand and
manipulate and the patent has expired
so we can all use it and it will
probably be going into Bitcoin and some
some cryptocurrencies use our signatures
I think Manero uses a snore like
signature but Bitcoin will probably be
it will be they'll be putting it into a
Bitcoin in the next year or so so all
these things will be much more
applicable and you can use them and you
can and there's code out you can use
them now okay yeah sorry patent expired
free to use the better I'll go that must
not be named so yeah we're maybe not
like people don't call it Schnoor
signature as much because it's like well
this is the guy who prevented us from
using this for 20 years and like and and
there's modifications to it okay so the
elliptic curve signature for lack of a
better name and this is something of a
simplification and there's like reading
about how you can really do it the right
way but this does give you the right
idea and for a single signer this is
also this is secure and it works but
later things you might want to actually
adds other stuff so the idea is you've
got your message M right same as in
Lamport same as in RSA you've got a
message m in a private key lowercase a
and your public key is a times G like we
said and then when you want to sign you
actually make a one-time use key pair
for the signature only and they usually
call that K and K is a new random number
it's the private key and you're gonna
multiply it by G and so R is sort and
they call this R I don't know why they
use these letters but anyway K times G
is our R is sort of the other public key
you're using just for this signature and
then the signature itself is quite
straightforward as the signer you
compute S which is K this new private
key you just made up - the hash of your
message concatenated with are this
public key so you encode the public key
and 33 bytes stick it in there
multiplied by a your your you normal
private key and then your signature is
the pair the R point and the S scalar
this is you know a little bit of a bunch
of the process but it's actually not too
bad right this is scalar 32 bytes you
made up the hash when you you know this
is a message also gonna be however long
this is 33 bytes you concatenate them
together hash you end up with another 32
byte scalar you multiply those two
scalars so actually there's no the only
elliptic curve operation here is
calculating what are s when you're
actually calculating s this is all just
scalar so it's very fast so in terms of
practical computer stuff doing these
operations is a little bit on the slow
side because you're doing those point
additions quite a number of times so
come so a decent code can and like a
decent CPU can do 10 like foul on the
order of thousands of these types of
operations per second which is decent
you know like you can do a decent amount
but it is kind of slow and it's it's
considerably slower than hash functions
you can do you know a million iterations
of hash function for a second on a core
or you can do maybe a thousand or two
thousand of this kind of thing
so still pretty fast but slower and so
this signing procedure this takes a bit
of time this takes actually very little
time because you're just subtracting and
multiplying scalar you know 32 bytes
scalar integers which is much faster ok
so does this make sense we'll go a
little bit about how you can't Forge
this okay sorry first verification sorry
so how would you if anyone knows how I
can think about how would you verify
this right I know I know their public
key capital a which is a you know a
little a times G and then they're giving
me a message m and they're giving me a
signature which is R and s and they've
computed it this way I can't verify this
equation myself because I don't know
what K is I don't know what little a is
right I'm just given R
s M
and so how would I verify this so the
basic idea yeah you're right
multiply this side by G then you also
have to multiply the other side by G
right so you say okay well I'm gonna
multiply it I I'm as the verifier I've
got our got s I multiply F by G and now
I have to multiply this side by G and
what will that look like
well what's K times G all right what's
little a times G big a so so yeah I want
to verify I want to verify this that
this equation was used right s equals K
minus this hash times little a multiply
both sides by G I get s times G equals
to K times G minus the hash thing times
little a times G this is big a this is
our hey now I know everything here as
the verifier right I know what s time
she is I know what R is I know what big
a is I know what's going into this hash
function and so I just say okay well you
know I rearranged it a little and say is
R equal to this and if it is that's a
good signature if it's not it's not a
good signature any questions about this
is this
make sense mostly so for the
verification there's a bit it's a bit
more CPU intense right you're you're
given a scaler you multiply by G you're
also you also have to multiply a this is
actually more costly you have to
multiply a by this hash the reason
that's more costly it's still a scalar
times a point
the thing is since G is used for
multiplying a lot you pre compute all
sorts of coefficients times G and you
store them like in RAM or in your like
CPU somewhere so so multiplying by G is
a little bit faster because you you do
it a lot you can pre-compute a lot
whereas multiplying by a is different
each time for all the different
signatures so this is a little bit
slower in general so it's a little bit
it takes a little bit more CPU time to
verify a signature than to create one
something like twice as much but still
you can do this pretty fast on a modern
computer you can do thousands of these a
second okay any questions so far and
I'll go a little bit into why this is
not for Jim all right so I want to forge
a signature well why don't I make up a
kit you know I don't know little a but
why don't I make up a K and compute SNR
but I need a right so I'm gonna say okay
I this is the equation I want I'll just
make up my own K and make up my own K s
that solved that you know that's the
satisfy this without a I really can't
make a valid s right I can make
something up here but I can't compute it
cuz I don't know here right I can try
keep I can try to grind through hash
functions but it won't work the basic
problem is if I make up an S and solve
for R right I can say well I know what R
is but the thing is are is in the hash
function as well it's the it's the
one-wayness of the hash function that
actually breaks this right so let me
solve for R well R is the hash of M
our times a plus s times G if I can come
you know if I can come up with a random
with a valid are here I can do this
the problem is R is defined by the hash
of R in this case I can't compute this
and I can't cancel this out right so if
you can see this like okay I need to
solve for R well but it's already in
here like I'm stuck if I don't know K I
can't come up with a signature either
one okay there is one sort of foot gun
with EC signatures if you use the same R
value for different signatures with the
same pump key you reveal your private
key so K has to be random and new every
time I you you mean that if you if you
look through the question you'll see how
you can solve if you know if you have to
live the same case with differences you
can solve for K and then once you solve
for K given given this if you know what
K is you can find what little a is right
as a verifier you can say well I know
you you gave me s that's part of the
signature I know this whole coefficient
if I know K I can solve for a little a
by dividing this out so always use a new
K value there have been many cases where
people don't probably the most famous
one is Playstation 3 used ECDSA and they
used a fixed K value for signing all
their code and that allowed people to
calculate their private keys and then
run pirated games that was actually the
first time I learned it occurs like 2010
or sup so actually there's there's kind
of interesting tutorials written by like
the hackers who broke a Playstation 3
about how this works and that's what I
first write about it
okay we're almost out of time any
questions about this stuff so far okay
so other so this is
this is a signature algorithm it's like
okay fine this works I can sign same as
Lamport signatures same as RSA what's
really nice about the elliptic curve
stuff is you can do more than just
signatures there's all sorts of fun
things you can do and it seems like a
fairly unexplored area in that like I've
found fun things that you can do that
are you guess our novel and like I don't
I'm not an expert on this at all it's
just that it's a fairly new area of
research and like how to do cool Bitcoin
e cryptocurrency things with these
curves and points and stuff so I'll go
through a couple fun things you can do
fun with points okay so I'm not using an
asterisk so I'm just you know B times G
so let's say Alice has a public key a
Bob has a public key B right which is
little a times G or little B times G
well this is weird little a times big B
Alice's private key multiplied by Bob's
public key you can do that right is
equal to Bob's private key times Alice's
public key right it's commutative the
multiplication is commutative that's
weird right it's just a times G times B
which is the same or you know it doesn't
matter the order it's the same as B
times G times a which is the same as a
times B times G and let's call that C
see this is called the diffie-hellman
key exchange point Diffie and Hellman
are two also like late 70s PhD students
who came up with all this cool stuff no
wait if he was a PhD student Hellman was
his advisor I don't remember
anyway they came up with this idea and
this is this is like a shared point what
would this be useful for it's actually
super useful and can you think of like
oh okay we can do this we can compute C
why would we want to do that like any
applications you can think of yeah
yeah it's really cool to share keys so
this is also done if you have a web
browser I think it's all looked a curve
diffie-hellman now mostly but if you
have a web browser and you go to a
website this is happening basically for
every HTTP request because you can use
see as they sort of shared key and
encrypt things with it the idea is a can
be public big a can be public big beep
can be public point C will not be public
the only way to compute it is to know
either a is private you know Alice's
private key little a or Bob's private
key little B even though you can see you
can see the public keys you can't
compute C by from just the public keys
right because big a times big B that's
not defined and that would that wouldn't
even be that like you can't multiply the
points you have to multiply the point by
a scalar and since you don't know the
scalars from viewing this exchange
you can't compute C but Alice and Bob
can both compute C so this is really
useful you can compute C you can use it
for encryption you can use it to prove
you are who you say you are you can use
it as like an interactive verification
where you say okay I'm gonna I'm Bob I'm
gonna make a random point I'm gonna give
that to you prove you know your private
key little a by telling me what C is
right so I can I can I can make like a
random key here give it to you you
return see I verify that that's the
right C I say okay well you must know
little a you haven't shown me little a
but I even that you know it so proof of
knowledge of the private key so you can
use that for like logins instead of
passwords and it's like much simpler
than a signature so that's really cool
all sorts of things you can do with that
the last part you can have fun with
points and I use this in my software so
you say ok well there's a public key a
there's a public key B
and well we'll define D as the sum of
these two public keys the thing is if
it's if you're selling these two public
keys it's community it's the same as
saying the sum of the two private keys
times G right a times G Plus B times G
is the same as a plus B times G which is
another really cool property so what if
I compute this prior to this public key
D and I say I want a signature from
public key D you can and you saw the
private key little D which can sign for
this is just little a plus a little B so
you can make a combined key and then
either party you know Alice has a little
a Bob has little B and they could reveal
it to each other and allow the other
person to make a signature with D later
this is this is yet like I use this in
the lightening up network software I've
had where basically you say look we'll
compute D and like I can give you the
private key right I know I'm you know
I'm Bob and I say okay here's here's
point be yours point a we add them
together and then Alice I if I give you
my private key now you can sign but I
can't write so I'll like sort of give
you the private key to D from some
information I have or you could give me
the private key to D by sharing a little
a with me so this is another useful
thing where you can have something where
both parties know that neither party can
sign unless they give them something and
you can use that for like Bitcoin
addresses things like that this is like
sort of before you even get to
signatures you can share keys and stuff
there's a there's all sorts of super fun
things you can do with these points and
curves and systems multi signatures is
like the the reading I put a link to a
PDF file it's like very recent and like
kind of overkill and like over my head
as well but you can do signatures where
you a great the signatures but there's
ways to sort of say okay well I'm gonna
add all these are points and I'm gonna
add all these s points and I can have
signatures that are
from a bunch of different people that
collapse into the same size as a single
signature and I can verify that they're
all signing the same thing or possibly
that they're all signing different
things so I have you know ten different
signatures from different people signing
different messages but I can add up all
the s values I have to keep the R values
but now these ten signatures instead of
being 64 bytes each are more like 32
bytes each and there's one extra 32 byte
value for all of them
so there's a lot of really cool ways you
can like combine things make things
smaller make things really versatile
where we can share keys things like that
which you can't do with hash based
signatures hash functions and so it's
really fun one worry is that if quantum
computers ever become really a thing all
this stuff stops working all the
elliptic curve stuff doesn't work
anymore you can you can figure out what
people's private keys are
whereas hash stuff hash things like limp
or signatures still work so there's some
some talk of like hey we should sort of
prepare for if that ever happens and
make you know efficient effective hash
based signatures and use them in
something like Bitcoin or aetherium
people haven't yet because the overhead
is really high it's really big but and
it's the the real thing is all these fun
things might disappear in the next 10 20
years who knows but there's lots of cool
stuff what do we do with this
so we we're not gonna do anything yep in
terms of problem sets it's a little hard
to program it directly but there's
libraries and the libraries have fairly
easy use where it's like you know x G is
a function and like x this point as a
function so this is ground worth for
cool stuff you can do and it's really
nice because it's a new area and like
I'm not an expert on this but I've come
up with stuff that I don't know people
have sighted me on and they're like yeah
I guess no one thought of that before
there's a lot of things there's one very
recent one called taproot where it's
like one line you're like oh yeah that
works and it's just these sort of
elliptic curve operations it's like yeah
that works that's really useful how did
it know one thing is that like it's one
line like wow so there's just not a ton
of people working on this kind of stuff
and so it's kind of fun